Before we say goodbye, we love to play a quick round
of "Drewth or Dare".
(audience cheers)
And since we're celebrating "Scream" today,
we actually have two huge "Scream" fans here.
It's Jenna and Destiny.
Hi.
(audience cheers)
Now, in "Drewth or Dare",
usually, I'll say or do anything.
Anything.
Because I'm game.
Uh-hmm.
But, actually, I'm gonna hand this one over to you today.
Take it away.
Thank you.
I wrote a little something, 'cause I write a lot.
I write a lot of poetry,
but I knew today, I needed a little help.
(paper rustling)
(clears throat)
Destiny.
Oh, God. (laughs nervously)
Our story is one of growth, communication,
unwavering support, and love.
We might not have started because of "Scream",
but our journey and our love has flourished
through all the adventures and the amazing people
that we've met along the way.
We are here because of all of those people and you
and just everybody that lifted us up.
Now, I know you were bummed
because you didn't have a family heirloom
to pass down between you and your brothers from your grandma
when she passed, but your mom had that taken care of
behind the scenes.
It is an honor to have this opportunity
and an even bigger one to ask you this
with the ring that belonged
to your favorite person, your grandma.
I am so lucky and we are so lucky.
So Destiny Justine,
oh, God.
Will you marry me?
Of course, yes.
(audience cheers)
Oh, boy (indistinct).
(indistinct talking)
(audience cheers continuously)
Oh, I'm so happy for you.
Thank you so much.
Oh.
Should we ask our question?
I am so happy for you both.
How do you feel?
I'm so happy (indistinct).
(audience cheers)
(indistinct talking)
Oh, I love that, I'm so happy for you.
And you know what's so beautiful?
Is that you choose each other, you know?
And that's the hope for all of us, you know?
That we might get to choose somebody
or that somebody chooses us to choose to love,
to be brave enough to love,
to show that love.
Thank you for doing it here with us today.
It's such an honor.
No, it's an honor.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
I love love, I can't help it.
It's so great.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank you so much.
Thank you for choosing to spend your time with us.
We make this show for you so take it with you.
(upbeat outro music)